دانت وكيله الامين العام للامم المتحده
روزماري دي كارلوس استهداف البنيه التحتيه
في اوكرانيا وقالت ان اكثر من الف هجمه
اثرت على المنشات الصحيه والتعليميه هناك
كما دعت الى وقف الهجمات على المناطق
المدنيه سواء في اوكرانيا او في روسيا
دعوني اكرر مره اخرى الهجمه ضد المدنيين
والمنشات المدنيه محظوره بموجب القانون
الدولي كل تلك الهجمات يجب ان تتوقف فورا
سواء كانت في الاراضي الاوكرانيه او روسيه
او الاراضي التي تسيطر عليها روسيا
وخلال الجلسه نفسها جددت المندوبه
الامريكيه الدائمه لدى الامم المتحده
ليندا توماس مواصله دعم اوكرانيا في
دفاعها عن نفسها في مواجهه العدوان الروسي
حسب تعبيرها كما اتهمت جرين فيلد روسيا
بانتاج مسيرات ايرانيه داخل اراضيها
لمهاجمه الاهداف المدنيه الاوكرانيه
نحن نعلم ان الكريم
مع ايران لانتاج هذه الاسلحه داخل روسيا
في الاسابيع الاخيره استخدم الكريم هذه
المسيرات لتدمير البنيه التحتيه
الاوكرانيه وقتل وترهيب المدنيين يجب على
الامم المتحده تنفيذ قرار مجلس الامن رقمي
مازلنا لا نملك اي تفسير لعدم ارسال خبراء
الى اوكرانيا لمراجعه الادله على اصول هذه
الاسلحه والدمار الذي تسببت فيه
قال المندوب الروسي في الامم المتحده غسيل
نيفينزيا ان اوكرانيا تسعى من خلال الهجوم
المضاد الذي وصفه بالفاشل الى لفت انتباه
الغرب اضاف المندوب الروسي في جلسه بمجلس
الامن عن الوضع في اوكرانيا انه لم تسجل
اي هجمات روسيه على المدنيين منذ انطلاق
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
يسعى نظام كيف من خلال ما يسمى الهجمه
المضاده الفاشله الى اعتماد تكتيك اخر
للفت انتباه الغرب ويوجه اصابع الاتهام
الى روسيا نؤكد ان كل تلك الممارسات لن
تمر مرور الكرام ووفد الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه كان قد زار محطه
انطلاق الهجمه المضاده الفاشله لم تسجل اي
هجمات صاروخيه روسيه او من خلال مسيرات
على مناطق مدنيه اوكرانيه